he is in his dining room off the white  off the Oval Office watching it and  almost giddy because I mean he does  watch a lot of TV but here he is seeing  thousands of his supporters basically  trample up to the steps break through  barricades all rallying for him to try  to stop the certification of the  election for Joe Biden and he feels  really supported and emboldened by that  and again giddy of course he was  of course he was this really shouldn't  be surprising to anybody Donald Trump  seemed to at least for some period of  time on January 6th believe these people  might actually overthrow the election  results overthrow the government that is  set to be sworn in just two weeks later  and install me as president which would  basically be becoming a dictator right  he he would have lost but somehow been  installed by force